[Music]
you're very young but as a kid
i've i've heard that you were not afraid
like a lot of kids are trying to conform
not you that was not your way as a kid
you wanted to try and challenge social
norms is that right do things
differently almost on purpose yeah i was
really into just kind of tormenting my
parents by like asking for things that
were completely unreasonable and i one
thing i tried for a while was eating
dinner in the shower i was like adamant
that i that that was going to be a great
time saver i was always really concerned
well that's just a sign of mental
illness more than exercise
eating dinner in the shower i can't
cause you can't like shampoo and eat a
steak at the same time like scalp
potatoes doesn't work in the shower it
doesn't taste good with water i mean
like i don't know rice pudding was a
highlight but like that was kind of i
think a popsicle works if it's not a hot
shower it's a good idea it's a cold
shower a popsicle's fine i don't want to
give anyone that visual but yeah that's
a pretty good one
[Applause]
let's move on um
you ever do stuff like that eat in the
shower no no not eat in the shower no
okay there's a whole unspoken no i think
i'm going to leave it
i'm not i'm not going to say another
damn word
all right all right short term 12 uh i
don't want to embarrass you but your
performance is absolutely stunning a lot
of there's a lot of
oscar buzz a lot of people talking about
your performance a lot of excitement and
uh it really is a stunning performance
we have a clip
uh to show and what can you tell us
about this scene
um well this is a scene kind of early on
in the film um i play a
a line staff at a short-term foster care
facility so i'm kind of the person who
does deals with her day to day so this
is the movie deals a lot with the day to
day and this is part of the highs and
lows
right you're working with a lot of young
kids who have a lot of issues and the
movie's really about you establishing
this really incredible relationship with
this one girl but let's take a look at
this clip from short term 12.
hey everyone
i think most of you already met her but
we have a new member of our community
jaden would you introduce yourself
um
please don't be offended if i'm not very
friendly but
i'm gonna be living with my dad soon and
i don't really like wasting time on
short-term relationships so you know
it's nothing personal
wow she seems like a really nice girl
hey i think we all can respect her space
okay
okay what do we want to play for rec
today whiffle ball dude okay oh man
you're always playing this stupid game
because you always suck at it until you
get good at it maybe we can stop playing
it watch your mouth bro both of you cut
it out
any other suggestions
yes sammy can we play big and small
is that a real game or is that a game
you just made up
it's a real game that i just made up
okay
well maybe you can explain that to me
later
i identify with that
i said movie i'm boy
that's me